yeah I we look to signal in patient
before which is sort of often tangent
okay I'll forget it come back to what we
were looking at earlier choose my
arithmetic progressions not to be
confused with arithmetic arithmetic is
the noun like I'm good at arithmetic
right whereas arithmetic is the
adjective because it's a descriptive
word so those are arithmetic sequences
before or progressions and in an AP turn
it for sure each successive term what
what kind of different one turned to
another you're adding something or
you're subtracting something to a
tentative constant so we say each
successive term has a common difference
right that's how we call it deep okay so
G please take this idea and this just a
little okay since they're adding or
subtracting a constant the idea in a GP
is rather than addition or subtraction
multiplication or division
so each successive terms this is you
each successive term energy P rather
than having a common difference has a
common ratio right so for instance so
far we would think you know hailey even
numbers and those are they're getting
bigger by two every time right well if
we multiply by two every time what kind
of series would we get right well for
example you guys died one actually
decide any way you'd like right but if I
multiply by two to get each successive
term on it 1 plus 2 4 plus 8 and so on I
suppose we could write this as you know
1 times
^ 0 right because that's just the first
term so there's no 2 in there the next
one would be the first term again I have
to start from there and then I multiply
it by 1 lot of the common ratio so to
power 1 it's 2 and then the next one
would be okay so like we said before we
call the common difference D so I
suppose it makes sense to call the
common ratio
ah ah I don't know how well picks you up
because the facing okay so do you
remember we said before generally
speaking an AP if we were to name it
supposed to turn pain right
it'll be a plus a plus D there's the
first one and then a plus 2 D so on okay
so because we're multiplying not adding
energy P the first step will still be
back you're still calling whatever state
this one won't be a plus in we need a
times the ratio right yeah and then the
next one will be 8 times the ratio times
the ratio camp so R square and so on
okay so again reviewing your member the
in term of AP was the first term plus
how many watts of the common difference
it's the intern - one loss right
so just the same way for a GP right
the emptor will be the first term times
how many lots of the common ratio just
like before
n minus 1 right right that's how you can
see the first term has the lots of are 0
lot the second term is 1 mark the third
term has two months and that's where
that n minus 1 is appear so we we used
this idea to come up with what's the sum
of the first n terms right and the way
we did it was we paired them up so there
are n terms there we end on two pairs
and then when we simplify we had this ok
so we took advantage of the pairing
thing that's a mega happen so you just
imagine what I'm going to close next to
you if if this is the way an arithmetic
progression works how does a geometric
point work how would you work out the
sum of a geometric series
how would you work out what a geometric
series evaluates to I'll give it to the
paragraph it doesn't quite work the same
way so that you guys have a think about
it and see how would you work this out
do you play around with the number of
turns in a G major progression and see
for some invested